[Musique]
on va vous transformer un peu en forme
parce que ça vous amuse enfin archi
sophistiquée je veux dire pas du tout
vous avez pas envie parce que je suis
très bien comme je suis là je trouve
gâcher votre image de marque non non
c'est pas une image de marque mais je me
vois pas le matin en me levant comme ça
avec des robes des talons très hauts
le soir
sont tendu la trop une idée de vous
d'ailleurs moi avec lui-même un jour que
vous vendez votre gueule plus que votre
disque vous l'avez dit vous-même oui
c'est vrai ça alors mais moi j'aime bien
travailler comme ça d'accord
un peu comme dirait j'ai hop je sais que
c'est le mot je veux pas le dire
c'est quand même la petite Marilyn
monroeula ça rappelle quand même tu es
un débarboule et pourtant j'aime bien
cette Maryline mais ça y est ce t-shirt
que vous cachez soigneusement
[Musique]
pensez à demain vous croyez ça vous
amuse pas parce que ça peut donner que
vous connaissez pas vous-même si ça
m'amuse mais je sais pas j'ai jamais mis
de robe très souvent on va vous mettre
une robe qui ressemble pas au rap que
vous portez d'habitude des gants comme
Rita et votre emporter dans Gilda des
talons hauts mais beaucoup plus haut que
vous avez là au moins les 14 15 cm
[Musique]
ça fait ça oui au moins c'est très
facile vous verrez il suffit de vouloir
parce que là ça marche tout seul
[Musique]